Continuing in Al-Wajeez
And today the author begins to discuss
the topic of Al-Aaniya.
Baab
Al-Aaniya.
Ish Al-Aaniya?
Jammu Inaa.
Wal Inaa
Ma yuj'alu feehi
min
ta'aamin aw sharaabin aw mataa'in.
Fahadha yusamma inaa'un.
Wal Ulamaa
ja'alu hadha al-baab aw hadha
al-mab'hath fee hadha al-mawdi'
min kutubil
[Silence]
And so, today we're going to discuss the
author now takes us into a topic that
at first glance seems
strange that it would be in this place.
That this would be the
place that the author chooses
to do this research.
And that is the issue of
containers.
Containers, that's what an aniyah is.
And an inah is a containers.
What is a container? Something that
holds contents.
Right? Whether that's food, whether
that's water, whether that's
whatever it is. This is referred to as
an inah.
It seems out of place at first.
You think to yourself,
we just got This is the book of
purification.
We just got We just got done speaking
about
the etiquettes of the restroom and
relieving oneself.
Why would we now switch
to
a chapter
that is going to
research the topic of
or address the topic of containers.
And that is correct. That assumption is
correct. Because when we really look at
this topic especially especially
the way that the author
has
explored this topic, we'll realize
that this topic especially for this
author in this particular book
belongs in the chapters or the books
regarding
regarding food, drink, meats,
that which
are dietary
chapters, chapters regarding the diet
rather than things like
purification. However, traditionally
the authors
of fiqh
have more or less
all settled on this order to their books
of fiqh, more or less. Especially the
late latter
scholars of fiqh. And they will usually
research this topic right here right
smack dab in the middle of the chapters
and the
regarding purification.
Why? Because a person uses a container
of some sorts to make wudu or make
ghusl.
And not all containers are permissible
to be used
as we will hear from the author.
And so because of this
it is more relevant to the everyday
Muslim
to hear about it earlier than wait
for however many books or chapters
later to arrive at it
finding out something is impermissible
in wudu or ghusl
that belongs there but wasn't mentioned
until chapters and chapters later.
Right? That's the idea.
The author
is of the opinion that it is permissible
to make wudu and ghusl in out of any
container.
Whether this container be made of
diamonds,
gold, silver,
wood, pottery, anything.
It is permissible to make wudu
out of any container.
However, that is not the opinion of the
majority of the scholarship of Islam, as
we will hear.
The majority of the scholarship of Islam
view wudu or ghusl made directly
out of a container of silver or gold is
considered to be
either impermissible or invalid.
Notice the words here, impermissible or
invalid.
Why impermissible or invalid?
Because
not everything done
that is impermissible will necessarily
invalidate. Let's say a person stands to
make salah.
It's not permissible for a man to wear
silk, right? Let's say to cover his
awrah he uses silk clothing. He wears
garment made out of silk.
Is his salah valid or invalid?
Difference of opinion amongst the
scholars.
A person goes to make salah
on a piece of land that he stole.
Is the salah valid or invalid?
Difference of opinion amongst the
scholars. They all agree that this
person has done something haram,
but they have differed on whether or not
that
invalidates their
act of worship, which we will research
when we arrive at those chapters,
inshallah.
And so, that is why this
topic is explored here. It's kind of
like
the rulings of janazah, funeral prayer,
or funeral processions.
a rather small part of funeral
processions
is the salah,
the funeral salah. It's actually,
you know,
ratio-wise, compared to the rest
of the rulings of the funeral and what
we go through in order to prepare
someone for their send-off,
salah is 1/10 of all of the
rulings.
Right? It's rather small. It's short
contrasted with the rest of the rulings
of bathing and shrouding and the way
that the hole is dug and where the hole
is dug and what constitutes a grave and
how graves are
etc.
However,
almost unanimously, across the board,
the scholars of fiqh will place
the chapter
the chapters of funeral processions and
the rulings of funerals where? In the
book of salah.
In the book of salah. Why? Because they
will usually mention and explore a topic
in its entirety
at the first relevant place
in their books of fiqh. And most books
of fiqh
are structured after the structure of
al-Bukhari.
How did al-Bukhari structure his book
Sahih al-Bukhari?
He structured it according to the
narration of Jibreel
alayhis salaam.
the pillars of Islam, right?
[Arabic recitation]
Ramadan.
And so
that's how he structured his book.
And
most of the scholars of fiqh after him
followed in suit.
And
even al-Bukhari followed largely the
structure of the first book of fiqh
written ever.
What is the first book of fiqh ever
written in the history
of Islam?
Ar-Risalah.
Huh?
Ar-Risalah Kitab fi Usul al-Fiqh.
Ar-Risalah is a book on hermeneutics of
fiqh.
Anyone else?
What do you think? What would you guess?
If you had to guess, what is the first
book of fiqh ever written?
[Arabic recitation]
What is it?
The Quran?
No.
That's not a book of fiqh, huh?
Muwatta Malik?
Very strong. Very strong opinion.
Very You're You're so close in
everything you say. And actually, I kind
of
I kind of
was not really upfront with you.
Al-Risalah is a book on usul al-fiqh.
But al-
is a book on fiqh. Al-Risalah is often
times considered to be the first volume
of Kitab al-.
Al-Shafi'i
has a book called al-.
The
reference.
That's what it would translate to.
And it is the first book written on the
topic of fiqh.
And that is when fiqh
branched off and became an
independent science from hadith.
Before that,
you wanted fiqh, you'd look for it in
the books of hadith.
Right? That's where it is.
However, when al-Shafi'i
wrote
his book al-,
and later it was compiled into a
greater, more broader body of all of his
works, his earlier madhhab and his
latter madhhab,
or also known as the madhhab of Iraq and
the madhhab of Egypt,
this is all gathered into one book
called al-.
This is marking the first point in the
history of Islam
when the science of fiqh became so
researched that it became a specialty
on its own. Became an independent
science from Hadith.
All right?
And so, he structured that book in a
very meticulous way, but largely
structured his book after the book of
Muwatta Malik, his Sheikh.
Because the book of Muwatta Malik is
more than just a book of Hadith, it has
in it a lot of
his opinions and
Muwatta Malik Hadith and so forth.
As-salamu alaykum Subhanahu wa ta'ala
and you forget everything in the one
year you are learning
my info on and you find me learning
Allah and Allah bless our prophet
[Arabic recitation]